ah
[Música]
si les digo que los alemanes también
toman mate
es más si les digo que en berlín hay más
de 15 marcas que comercializan mate con
ventas y facturaciones altísimas me
creen
les voy a contar una historia
yo viví muchos años en barcelona en
españa y me hice muy amigo de max martin
es un 100% berlín es que como muchos
extranjeros en contacto con uruguayo se
hizo adicto al mate
es más max te prepara los mejores mates
que he tomado en mi vida con él compartí
termos mates y charlas interminables
hace cuestión de un año me llama y me
dice él está estudiando medicina en
berlín y me dice que tiene que venir
tiene que elegir una ciudad del mundo
para hacer su pasantía y recibirse de
médico y elige montevideo más
precisamente el hospital pasteur para
venir a hacer su práctica de seis meses
me acuerdo todavía cuando lo fui a
buscar el aeropuerto de carrasco llegó
con su mochila al hombro una bicicleta
colgada y una caja
max que poca cosa que trajiste para seis
meses no una caja una mochila y la
bicicleta dice no esta caja es para ti
esto es te dije que en berlín tomamos
mate solo traje la mochila
esto es todo para ti me da la caja abro
15 botellas de 15 marcas distintas de
refresco de mate creo que por acá
justin gracias tenemos alguna
precisamente club mate la número uno de
todas estas refrescos de mates alemanes
100 por ciento alemanes producidos en
alemania
max no lo puedo creer contame un poco de
esto tendencia en berlín la toman en las
universidades en los que works de noches
las toman en las discotecas las mezclan
con alcohol es como un red bull pero
natural el mate estimulante cafeína esto
es impresionante max la verdad no lo
estoy
no lo puedo creer llamo a mi amigo pepe
a mis amigos y actual socio pp un
emprendedor de maldonado también divino
el joven y te tenés que probar esto
empezamos a probarlas de noche no lo
podíamos creer esto está buenísimo esto
está genial y ya que pasa cuando dos
emprendedores un alemán adicto al mate y
15 refrescos de mate en una misma escena
esto hay que traerlo uruguay esto hay
que importarlo si vamos a traerlo si
esto autogol empieza autobombo cebarse
llevarse nunca mejor dicho ese bar se
este es el momento ideal los uruguayos
estamos re openmind ahora con el tema de
la cerveza artesanal tomamos cerveza con
gusto a zapallo a chocolate con lúpulo
de la flor de la india cuscús de
marruecos tomamos batidos verdes con
espirulina refresco de mate es perfecto
una idea tan obvia y se le escurrió o
sea donde mejor puede funcionar un
refresco de mate que en uruguay el país
queda mal mate estoy yo en ese momento
ya me imaginaba acá usted contando mi
idea maravillosa todos ustedes pensando
cómo se le ocurrió y como no la vimos
como no la vimos bueno
max empieza a ayudarnos llamada
alemanias
agencias/ede - agente o mate uruguay
club marcha en dos semanas éramos los
representantes exclusivos del club mate
en uruguay país 78 en el mundo si en 78
somos uruguay el 78 perfecto nada puede
salir mal vamos a comprar hacemos el
giro alemania euros cuanto compramos
podíamos haber comprado mil botellas no
sé qué le parece mil votos
la idea es demasiado buena nos vamos a
quedar cortos se van a acabar nos vamos
a querer matar entre lo que demora que
trae en el otro contenedor traigamos
2000 bote 5.000 botellas bastan traemos
el contenedor entero 10.000 botellas
el contenedor entero de un refresco de
mate que no conoce ni dios
en el país donde después de 100 años
empezamos a tomar el mate con un poquito
de jengibre
la hierba de
el desafío era grande pero nosotros
estábamos con todas con todas esto la
rompemos somos emprendedores somos así
somos soñadores así que el 15 de
noviembre hace ahora exactamente casi un
año
mandamos la plata para alemania y nos
ponemos a esperar el contenedor que
tenía que llegar a los primeros días de
enero imagínense empezamos a soñar punta
del este enero que está la playa todo el
mundo tomando club mates bandas de rock
no te va a gustar emiliano con él con la
que un mate una cosa
no puede salir mal
en enero el contenedor no llegó
pero en febrero tampoco
en marzo todavía hacía calor
pero no llevo el contenedor estaba
en abril
tampoco pero llegó en mayo junto con los
primeros fríos polares
no importa le damos al cálculo esas
cosas pasan que sabe los emprendedores
algunas veces cerramos a cosas y el tema
de las importaciones siempre es
complicado pero llega el contenedor nos
llama al despachante de aduana chicos al
fin llegó vamos a ahorrar números vamos
a sacar el contenedor del puerto
perfecto ahí vamos
o camisa despachante de aduana
les cuento que las importaciones en
uruguay no nos pagan el iva por
adelantado
sabiendo pero además los refrescos
tienen otro impuesto que sólo tiene la
nafta y los refrescos
que se llama imesi y también se paga por
adelantado
bueno cerramos también al número que
damos con el agua al cuello no a la
nariz
pero por fin liberamos el contenedor
estamos prontos para vender club mate el
día que salimos a vender nos llaman y
nos dicen no pueden venderlo porque
porque el documento de libre de venta no
vino apostillado en uruguay los
documentos del único país en el mundo
pluma te país 78 los alemanes no saben
lo que es la palabra apostillar
20 emails 15 llamadas conocemos a todas
las embajadas uruguayas en alemania
todas llega el papel apostillado ahora
si tenemos 10.000 preciosas botellas de
club mate
con su logo de lo que ellos piensan que
es un gaucho
en sus preciosas cajas
y estamos decididos a invadir todas las
cadenas más grandes de supermercados
tiene inglesa no le gustó disco no no de
voto no cinco no frob no macro no el
dorado en ropaje que pasó
qué pasó
es también un producto nuevo yo entiendo
pero
pensé que éramos un poquito más open
mind
bueno no falta publicidad es así una
cosa nueva no te lo aceptan es normal pp
es normal
influencers contratamos a la influencers
número uno en uruguay
pl
fama 200 mil followers en instagram
empieza a postear ella tomando pluma de
remate aquí que un material esto está
buenísimo tiene cafeína para la noche
genial ahora sí esto explotó
nos empiezan a caer followers en istán
yo estoy trabajo nunca work haya muy
lindo con otros emprendedores me suena
el teléfono
la influencia perdonen chicos hola
claudia como estas
explotando las redes explotando sí que
te llaman y que que te dicen qué
y después gloria
que se imaginan está explotando le
encanta a todo el mundo eso desearíamos
hasta este momento los he traído un poco
engañados en la charla para captar un
poco la atención de ustedes la verdad es
que club mate no le gusta a nadie
claudia
me llama y me dice la están comprando
todo el mundo baila compra pero dicen
que es espantosa
para que pasó tomamos cerveza de zapallo
pero la pluma te tiene gusto raro es
espantoso aunque quique
logramos con el lúpulo y todo el club
mate qué gusto raro que tiene
bueno
la verdad es que si estoy aquí enter y
es un orgullo y es una alegría pero en
realidad vengo a compartir una historia
de fracaso
[Aplausos]
gracias
y lo hago justamente por eso porque me
parece que es el momento ideal también
para que los uruguayos y los
emprendedores nos hagamos amigos del
fracaso nos riamos un poco juntos de los
errores que cometemos y nos volvamos a
levantar ideas del fracaso sale el
aprendizaje el fracaso es el principio
del éxito y de ahí sale la palabra
resiliencia tan de moda ahora con los
emprendedores les voy a contar un poco
en qué fallamos ahora la charla se pone
un poquito más seria
no sé vamos
nos fuimos al hueso trajimos un
contenedor entero
esto no estaba dentro del guión pero se
los voy a contar ya nos quedan cinco mil
pluma test y pensé en el mes que viene
ya en un acto desesperado fuimos con un
el importador más grande de todo uruguay
para decirle lo que por favor ustedes
traen pilas de cosas de alemania nos
mandamos está echemos una mano y nos
trajiste un contenedor entero y nosotros
hacemos eso traemos 500 productos al mes
bueno en fin
prueben
rápido y barato
a nosotros nos encanta probar lento y
caro
pero ya aprendimos
lo otro es el tema de los cálculos no
calculen positivamente las cosas siempre
salen mal siempre el contenedor tenía
que llegar en enero llegó en mayo
la botella tenía que costar 1 costó 3 el
tema del apostillado los trámites y
demás
por otro por último no pensamos en el
contexto un producto puede ser
maravilloso en un lugar de echo club
mate es un producto maravilloso que es
gluten free y vegano y en berlín se
vuelven locos
porque para ellos los acerca a nuestra
cultura los acerca a latinoamérica nos
acerca a la yerba mate a sentirse un
poco como cuando nosotros tomamos una
cerveza alemana importada o un whisky
escocés en un en un mismo producto en un
diferente contexto puede funcionar o no
puede funcionar nosotros no lo vimos eso
bueno para terminar la charla
aprovechando la oportunidad de que te
llega a todo el mundo
quiero mandarle un mensaje a mi amigo
max en berlín
max la próxima vez tráeme unas cervezas
yo te espero con unos buenos mates
[Aplausos]
ah